- Drunk on a horse is
not only a great idea
for a country song, but it's also a crime.
♪ It ain't drunk driving
if you're riding a horse ♪
- Now, the police in
Whittier, California arrested
a person on suspicion of
driving under the influence
after riding a horse through traffic.
Police said that the horseback rider
was galloping through traffic
and refused to pull the horse over.
This led to a brief chase, which ended
when the allegedly inebriated
rider simply gave up.
California law prohibits drunk riding.
California Vehicle Code
Section 21050 states
that people riding an
animal on state roadways
are subject to all of
the duties applicable
to the driver of a vehicle,
except those provision
which by their very nature
can have no application.
That means you can't drink and ride
if you are above the legal
blood alcohol limit of 0.08%.
So if this is the anonymous
rider's first DUI,
they face imprisonment of up to six months
and a maximum fine of $1,000.
And when a reporter asked,
"Why the long face?"
He replied, "I'm a horse,
and my rider just got pulled
over for drunk driving."